Film Courage: How much of you being a screenwriter
is about the love of writing so that a movie
can be made from that?
Is it something that is painstaking for you
where 10 hours will go by and you won’t
think of a line of dialogue?
Or is it something where you love the process?
Or you love it because it produces a movie?
Matthew Berkowitz, Filmmaker: Interesting…both.
I love the writing process.
I really do and I love being able to paint
pictures with words.
I love writing a story.
I love being able to tell a story over three
acts or two acts.
You can write a two-act film.
You can write these great characters.
I love writing.
Writing is such a passion for me.
But it’s also if you want to say something
there is not a better person to say it than
yourself.
So as a director sometimes you are forced
to write your own words because you want to
get your vision on screen.
So it’s never really come down to me trying
to create a product.
That’s not what screenwriting is to me to
create a product to go make a movie.
So that’s not really my intention as a screenwriter
but it’s always about me telling a story
I want to tell.
And I’ve co-written stuff with buddies and
friends and other writers.
But I really like at times being able to say
what you want to say as a director, what you
want to put on screen.
It doesn’t mean I don’t want to direct
other people’s words because I think that
is just as valuable.
As a necessity as a writer/director you have
a vision that you want to write that is in
your mind some place, that’s in the back
of your head that you can tap these beautiful
places and tell these beautiful characters
or scary characters and it’s easy to translate
it from your brain to your fingers to the
screen.
Film Courage: That’s interesting.
So it’s about getting out what you want
to say not about not having this thing where
“Look this is a movie and it’s screening
at this festival.”
It’s a burning desire to make a statement.
Matthew: Yes.
Film Courage: Have you always been like this?
Matthew: I’m sure if you asked my parents
they would probably say yes.
I’ve always been the one who wants to scream
really loud so…
Film Courage: Well you know certain kids are
more precocious and they have a statement
they want to proclaim to the world.
And then others were sort of the quiet ones.
So I just wasn’t sure.
Matthew: No I was the first one.
Yes I was hands down the first one.